hey I want to do a quick update about
when is the David Pakman show leaving
the current studio in Boston I made this
announcement earlier in the week I'm not
going to do it all again but if you
missed it the sort of like 15 second
version is we've been having massive
problems at our current studio noise
internet speeds all sorts of stuff we
are moving to a state-of-the-art
facility in Boston with much faster
internet proper soundproofing etc etc
etc we did not say exactly when this is
going to happen okay and I got a lot of
emails from people saying David you
mentioned the lease is ending but when
are you moving and what will the impact
be to the audience a couple things
number one we are planning on no
downtime as a result of the move what
I've done is retained our new studio
starting one month before our current
studio lease ends so there's going to be
a month of overlap there where we will
have access to both spaces the idea
being that there won't be like a
specific date on which we have to be out
of the old place and set up at the new
place and since a lot of the equipment
is going to be new anyway or can be very
easily moved from one place to the other
I'm not anticipating any period of time
during which the show is going to be
interrupted so that's number one as far
as the timeline goes I'm going to be
broadcasting from a conference in Las
Vegas
in early October and the plan is as soon
as I get back from that conference we
start the move over to the new studio
that should probably take somewhere in
the range of seven to ten days testing
and making sure everything's working
correctly so I would say mid to late
October we have to be out of our current
studio by the last day of October by
Halloween so certainly unless something
goes drastically wrong it's not going to
be after that real quick as far as the
discounted memberships I mentioned that
instead of doing like a big pre-emptive
IndieGoGo campaign or a Kickstarter
campaign to raise money for this
transition that
you've just decided to do it and we've
partnered with two longtime supporters
of the show who are willing to pay
thirty dollars for every person of the
first two hundred who sign up for a
membership at half price of those two
hundred memberships somewhere in the
forties remain a lot about a hundred and
sixty of those half price memberships
have been spoken for so if you want to
support this transition to a better
better produced program you can do it
but we only have about forty of those
half priced memberships left I will be
your personal membership concierge you
can reach out to me david at david
pakman.com i will get you a coupon code
if they remain for those half price
memberships let's take a break I'm on
Twitter at Dee Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we've
got a good one for you today